une espèce de molosses de deux mètres
qui me plaque au sol piqûre au cul femme
je me réveille la barre en quatre cinq
jours après nadal cher en camisole dans
une salle plus blanches et la tutelle et
cela je vous dis merde c'est là il
ajoute une merde lâche jamais rien
d'ailleurs m c'est quand tu es à l'hosto
après tout ce que tu peux tu viens un
espèce de produits du faire semblant
dont les médecins pour sortir le plus
vite possible tu prends les médocs tu
fais les tubes qui ferrait tout va bien
tout est bien une fois cette sorte sûrs
appareils chez toi et là tu dis [ __ ]
j'ai pu mais en fait j'avais mes quatre
boîtes qui tombait à l'eau j'avais
arrêté véhicule arrêté les études je
vais juste plein et du cou et les médocs
que je prenais qui me faisait prendre du
poids et maintenant que j'ai pris 25 kg
mon âge il avait perdu ça m'a pris deux
ans donc c'est cool mais donc mais tout
ça en même temps il suffit de rester dix
sept mois dans ma chambre
dix sept mois à me dire peter meer
pourquoi si pourquoi ça pourquoi si on
sait que c'est surtout ce que tu oublie
de dire c'est que dans la forme kaka
maxime il est passé d'un elena piquemal
ya donc qui que vous l'avez compris a
été cassée chimiquement plus long plus
de 100 mais il est retombé directement
dans un trou abyssal où effectivement
pendant 17 mois chaque soir quand je
m'étais la clé dans la porte je me
disais est ce qui me répond
[Musique]
ça ne m'amuse pas forcément être ici
avec ma mère mais je pense que c'est
important de témoigner parce que je suis
conscient qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
autour de moi qui ont la même pathologie
qui n'ont pas la chance d'être soutenu
écouté par la proche et que sur le mois
sans proches ça augmente vraiment le
risque d'aller dans le brut
c'est qu'elle te dire et donc qu'est-ce
que c'est la bipolarité
c'est un trouble psychiatrique de
l'humeur caractérisé à bases
neurologiques caractérisés par une
alternance entre des phases dites
déprécie dépressive hyper caractérisé
donc ça peut aller jusqu'au suicide et
des phases dites maniaque et avec un
retour à la normale entre les deux ça
touche environ 3% de la population
[Musique]
un jour la mère a reçu un coup de fil
dans les colloques sur place c'est relax
qui lui expliquer que j'étais devenu
plus ou moins contrôlable voilà je me
baladais à moitié à poil dans la rue moi
je faisais veut faire parce que je
voulais me marier avec une mannequin que
je n'ai rencontré j'avais décidé depuis
qu'elle est dans tous les sens j'ai
compris au travers des dealers de ses
amis que la situation était grave déjà
est très compliqué à contrôler puisque
puisqu'il ne se rendaient absolument pas
compte de son état et qu'il était qu'il
était en carence totale de sommeil qu'il
était qu'il allait créer quatre boîtes
en trois mois qu'il avait arrêté ses
études
enfin bref ça a été une bonne qualité
totale mais il se trouve que j'avais des
antécédents familiaux dont j'avais eu
connaissance finalement assez peu de
temps avant puisque comme dans beaucoup
de familles ce sont des sujets où
l'omerta règne et donc je savais que
j'avais eu un non plus dépressif mais
j'ignorais en fait qu'il avait aussi les
phases maniaques où il passait devant
une boutique il s'achetait une bagnole
alors qu'il n'avait pas besoin par
exemple et surtout j'avais un cousin
germain dont on m'avait dit qu'il était
décédé accidentellement et dont j'ai
découvert qu'il s'était suicidé et très
certainement pour parce qu'il était du
coup donc j'ai sauté dans un avion avec
des médocs rigoureusement interdit donc
j'ai planté ça dans une valise je suis
parti en me disant si j'ai passage j'ai
aucune chance de mettre mon fils dans un
avion et de le ramener en shootant moi
même donc je te dois de relier ouais je
les drogués sans lui dire j'ai menti de
a à z j'ai dit que j'étais là pour des
raisons professionnelles j'ai dit je
venais voir je n'avais pas du tout à une
fois arrivé à paris que ma tante
attendait une battante et médecins ont
même si le gens voient bien moi je suis
reste que j'avais là d'embêter les deux
laisse transpercé et le méga c'est
logique je veux dire ouais c'est bon
c'est vrai duré cinq minutes jeu pour
aller me reposer chez moi on m'a
embarqué mon fils je savais que les
molosses arrive
gt gt jusque là je ne sais pas même pas
trouvé l'adjectif est d'une violence
terrible quand on m'a dit que j'étais
bipolaire donc j'étais déjà tout seul
dans une salle blanche
il fait à ce moment là j'en ai vers la
mer énormément parce qu'elle m'a dit
rapidement avant de rentrer est ce qu'on
la sonitel parlais tout à l'heure c'est
qu'elle savait qu'il y avait un pipeau
l'air dans la famille et que personne en
avait parlé et du coup j'étais pas au
courant de ce que c'était donc moi même
comment me rendre compte d'une maladie
que j'ai possiblement si je sais pas ce
que c'est ce qui m'a vraiment aidé in
fine et c'est après donc cette première
au spi je fais avec une deuxième est en
fait pour la première fois je me suis
bon ok je suis hyper facile à assumer je
suis allée justement vraiment arrivé que
des bipolaires
alors je te prends parce que
l'acceptation c'est le début de la
guérison
d'après gérard la guérison entre
guillemets parce qu'on ne guérit pas
vous lâcher les mentonnais et ben ça
tombe bien ce qu'il voit la rivière je
ne sais pas être fier c'est le fait
d'assumer de l'actionnariat va avancer
dans la vie en avance marc est de
tourner en avance c'est vrai bhl est
malade et c'est vrai des accompagnants
aussi et croyez moi c'est pas facile
c'est important de savoir que
accompagner un bis colère c'est
apprendre à danser sous la pluie quand
quand c'est l'orage croire parce que
c'est leur âge tout le temps
[Musique]
non
mais enfin je tiens j'ai un peu prendre
le temps d'écouter des histoires des
autres et c'était majeurs et avant des
nanas jeté au visage et est en fait j'ai
compris que j'avais c'est là que j'ai
réalisé ce que la plupart étaient soir
là parce qu elle n'avait plus de famille
boulot je vais ensuite si tu fais une
crise et tu sors avec tap le taf je peux
plus payer son loyer enfin était tout
seul s'est passé et c'est là je suis
mais en fait c'était ça la solution pour
moi aussi au final c'est peut-être de
faim de bosser sur le sujet pour essayer
d'aider les autres même si je ne le
prends pas pour un savoir du tout mais
en moins de parler du sujet d'essayer de
faire avancer les choses encore une fois
et d'où l'idée que j'ai de créer cette
première association bipolaires i fihri
siens que j'écris d'ailleurs depuis
l'hôpital et le jour où jamie ils vont
te fait sentir de finale
[Musique]
non
kg est pas des malades pour des malades
mais aussi les proches puisque les
prochains
comme vous l'avez expliqué amer ne
savent pas où aller et aussi des
personnes qui se posent des questions
sur la santé mentale
puis on est de fous mais rêvait de la
camisole c'est le moment où il faut
connecter les gens
[Musique]